this is Austria's at star Valley idyllic
mountain panorama look at this it's
really beautiful here so quiet but
appearances can be deceiving
trust me this is another side of the
earth style this year it's home to the
extreme kayak World Championships 175
athletes from 30 countries are competing
for the title and Here I am in the
middle of it all everybody's looking for
the sick line the ideal caught through
the rapids this is one of the toughest
whitewater routes in the world some
parts are called champions killer or go
left or die who wants to put the other
stuff like this me but to be honest at
the moment I'm not quite sure if this is
a really good idea for me to try this
out to survive this challenge I'm
obviously going to need help from the
professionals here I'm pretty nervous
they recommend that i strengthen my
mental powers eat healthy food and I
will also need a bit of luck I'm the
lucky charm I've got almost stopped in
my GW back Deutsche Welle
that means German waves hello that must
be good omen this is the first year that
they will be crowning a woman's world
champion in this event no ways Marian
see there is one of the top candidates I
do it because it's really fun it's a
really it's a very clear challenge to
yourself and of course when you do it
nice that you feel very successful if I
want to try this out what will you tell
me I think if you go with someone that's
experienced that can teach you the
basics because you can't go along we
want to give you that confidence and who
could do that better than a three-time
world champion New Zealand Sam Sutton is
at the top of his game Sam be honest
what was the word thing that happened to
you
the closest school I've had is a few
times I've just been held underwater for
almost a minute or so and then you're
starting to wonder if this is it but
apart from that I've just broken my nose
several times you can kind of see it
right there it's pretty probably the
most crooked nose of it nevertheless you
need this adrenaline charge I mean you
want the the bigger the risk the bigger
the reward kind of thing in there
feeling of adrenaline seems that flows
through your veins as it's very
addictive how does it feel like it feels
him really similar to when you try to
land a plane it's exactly the same
feeling but you're just going down way
faster some Cayenne II fear but I think
that's wrong I think everybody naturally
has fear but it's about analyzing the
risk and saying like am I going to make
it and believing in yourself and you can
feel it so we're gonna go out and we're
gonna see Anna tandem [ __ ] if you've got
what it takes to potentially when the be
the queen of stick line for 2016
we are checking our gear one last time
before we head out in case we flip over
obviously if you're sitting up and I'm
trying to roll us uncle Milo your whole
upper body way to try and live to try
roll okay so I have to make me smoke
yeah
definitely I'm really really nervous
because I know there are some waterfalls
around the corner and we're off the
water is cold only about five degrees
Celsius and I soon find out how that
feels when we do our first Eskimo roll
no I'm sure that it couldn't get any
worse but I'm proven wrong when we get
to the steep decline I'm going down
back to the competition norway's Mary
and cedar won the first women's title he
is Sam Sutton out on the course and he
ends up in third place overall
congratulations
and I am also as happy as can be this
experience was really something I might
still be telling my children and
grandchildren about it when I'm old and
gray